meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
ausflug in die welt des mysteriösen des
magischen und das verwunderlichen hier
auf youtube auch in dieser folge werden
wir von deutschlands größter
berühmtester und potenteste geisterjäger
in mit dem namen rebecca ring
unterstützt in der heutigen folge so
viel kann ich ihnen an dieser stelle
schon einmal vorweg sagen wird es wieder
extrem großen blick und das kann die
ebenfalls dazu sagen wir werden mit
einem tatsächlichen lampenmast facetime
wenn ihr jetzt auch dran seid und euch
fragt oder was hast du da gerade eben
erzählt sollte es gibt für alles eine
vernünftige und rationale erklärung die
erklärung ist das rating wieder so tut
als würde sie mit horror charakteren
telefonieren diesmal ist es ein hat also
mehr oder weniger einfach so ein mast
mit sirenen obendrauf mal schauen was da
alles passiert der video titel verrät
cyrus hat also eine fiktive
menschenähnliche circa zwölf meter große
kreatur die keinen kopf hat sondern
sirenen als kopf rebecca wing in den
wald gelockt hat ok übrigens heute bevor
wir anfangen ganz kurzer blick nach
unten offenbart uns dass dies aktuell
wohl wieder ein trend für all jene
kanäle ist die zuschauer haben die
entweder nicht nachdenken wollen oder
nicht nachdenken können sind die prank
groß sind auch am start mit zeilen hat
videos schlecht läuft ihr verlobter
nummer in diesem fall ist es die
verfluchte nummer von haltet euch fest
einem literally telefonmast mit
lautsprechern obenan steht anstelle von
einem kopf versucht das ganze ausgeht
dass ich mein gründet das ist der
sogenannte cyber ist es jetzt natürlich
das nächste ding ja und von diesem
literally telefonmast auf beinen hat sie
jetzt die nummer bekommen
ausgecheckt ich habe sie nicht ein
gespräch ich habe nur diesen screenshot
auf meinem notebook
ach ja und erlaubt sie auch in den wald
also leute ich mein ich meine viele von
euch haben sich bestimmt gedacht okay
also wir haben hier einen telefonmast
der menschlicher ähnliche ausmaße hat
zwölf meter groß ist bei und arme hat
und sirenen lautsprecher als kopf soweit
alles okay ganz normal und er hat der
charmante telefonnummer also er hat
irgendwie ein vertrag bei vodafone oder
so so weit ganz normal aber er erlaubt
sich eine weiße seite
das ist damit das mysteriöse ja also
ganz ehrlich mittlerweile sind sich
einfach teilweise von diese videos und
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen die
tage wo ich noch ernsthaft bisschen
triggert zumindest ein bisschen
ernsthafter war die sind lange vorbei
leute gebt euch einfach das mittlerweile
ist es wirklich einfach zu uci was sich
die leute immer wieder neu aus denken
welche objektiven horb der mann jetzt
nicht anrufen darf oder welchen
spongebob katja diesmal ist es ein
tatsächlicher telefonmast auf bein ab
wann zählt das eigentlich als comedy
leute ganz kurze verständnis frage ich
show parallel auf dem handy nach meint
sich heftig talks die dieser telefonmast
der übrigen sind ja auch menschen ist
ist ja klar es ist ja logisch aber diese
telefonmast der menschen ist macht er
selbst hicks ist das was wir sagen
wollen
oh mein gott und sie gibt euch dass die
garage als zu krank 600.000 likes 1,7
millionen likes 540.000 leid 1,4
ok ok ja
hatte ich ja gesagt gibt die verfluchte
nummer von zehn fällen und ganz viele
meinten dann runter unter dem video
bitte suche nach der nummer was ich auch
zu krass finde leute ich hab das jetzt
gerade mal für euch übersprungen aber
sie sagt also rebecca sagt ja wirklich
das ist ja mittlerweile auch immer
diesen kanal eine weile verfolgen
sie sagt ja wirklich immer eins zu eins
das gleich am anfang von diesen videos
es ist ja wirklich eins zu eins gleich
also ich habe mich auch teilweise warum
die leute sich nicht irgendwie
langweilig fiel nach einer weile oder so
weil sie es ist ja jedes mal dasselbe
prinzip hängen geblieben
[Gelächter]
ich muss mal ich muss meine gehirnzellen
wirklich am leben halten
ich muss sie manuell ich möchte so
beatmen herz herzdruckmassage aber für
gehirnzellen abend machen ja leute es
ist das jahr 2020 wir schreiben ende
august 2020 und wie telefonieren mit
menschenfressenden telefonmasten mit sie
reden als kopf gibt es noch irgendwie da
draußen der irgendwelche fragen hat ich
habe mir gerade wirklich einfach eine
sache gedacht ich weiß ich lebe mich
damit vielleicht bisschen aus dem
fenster weil ich auch schon eine weile
reactions mache aber ich habe ja nicht
immer nur jacksons gemacht hat ich frage
mich wirklich ist das content ist das
controlling tut an dieser stelle wieder
einmal so als würde sie mit einem
telefonmast auf beinen mit einem
amerikanischen namen auf deutsch auf
whatsapp schreiben wieso wieso gibt es
so eine nachfragten an diesen videos
leute ich weiß mich einfach
davon halten so leute ich weiß nicht was
ich davon halten soll
ich weiß ich weiß es ist immer das
gleiche prinzip bei rebecca aber leute
check das einfach mal halter durch das
vor augen
ihr schreibt auf whatsapp mit einer
angeblich menschenfressenden kreatur
angeblich einem horror monster die leute
das was früher als es noch keine mods
abgab als ich noch bisschen jünger war
da haben die monster noch monster so
dass man sich okay da in dem bald ist
monster aufgefressen so heutzutage
schreiben mit den monstern teilweise auf
whatsapp wie soll das denn funktionieren
stelle vor das monster fängt grad einen
menschen so will den grat zur einstecken
und dann kriegst du was gemacht wird
sorry sorry ich würde dich gerade ich
wollte dich gerade gilt aber ich muss
kurz dieser einen youtube antworten für
die video ja da hat er gerade kurze
pausen otto becker das hast du ihn
gerade wahrscheinlich wieder beim unheil
verbreiten einfach gestört hätte
wirklich was besseres machen können er
hätte
guck mal hier zum beispiel hätte durch
neblige landschaften laufen können er
hätte leute erschreckt können hätte ganz
einfach sich unschuldige wanderer
einverleiben können oder auf seinen
serien knüpfen irgendwas bläst mit nein
rebecca will braucht einmal
aufmerksamkeit und er muss sich auch
verantworten
was für eine level ist das was ein level
ist das wirklich manchmal wenn ich
dieses video sehe denke ich nach darüber
nach wie ich einem normalen menschen
diese videos hier erklären
stellt euch vor jemand der nicht ganz
tief im youtube irgendwie ausgedachte
horror monster die dann auf einmal so
ein trend werden dann wieder
verschwinden modus drin sind wie erklärt
man das einer person so nach dem motto
ja ich habe ein video geschaut in dem
eine junge frau mitte 20 so tut als
würde sie auf what's up mit einem
monster schreiben wie soll irgendein
mensch der nichts mit youtube zu tun hat
dann noch denken dass wir als youtube
youtube macher und youtube zuschauer
eine gehirnzellen kann ich muss mich
wirklich mental davon distanzieren dass
ich mich da nicht zu sehr ein paar sätze
wenn ich immer diese videos sehr weil es
zählt wirklich mein leben es geht mein
leben es geht man erzählen und es geht
bei der einstellung war das ist einfach
so eine fiktive ausgedachte seltsame
milka kalter morgen wieder vom 12 meter
großen menschen fressenden telefonmast
in den wald gelockt werden gar keinen
bock
okay leute was sehen wir gerade rebecca
gibt einem telefonmast eine
menschenfressenden telefonmast jetzt
tipps wie er klar kommt er möchte ja
dass er weit kommt damit er sie auf
snacken kann und sich so nein ruft einer
von dem handy an und es stimmt
eigentlich warum rufe ich nicht den
psychotherapeuten für telefon messer an
ganz wichtig das darf natürlich auch
nicht fehlen der facetime anruf mal
schauen wie es aussieht wenn man mit
einem literally mit einem sirenen kopf
mit einer technischen anlage telefoniert
[Musik]
wir telefonieren also haben wir gerade
mit dem baum war nicht eigentlich sind
diese ganz angetan hat dass wir mit
irgendeinem monster telefonieren also
was irgendwie so ein ja halt so kein
baum ist eigentlich schon navas doch die
falsche nur was doch die nummer von
einem von einem baum
rebecca ja leute wieder mal ein video
was mich in meiner geistigen entwicklung
einige jahre zurückgeworfen hat jetzt
weiß ich dass es schon mal in
deutschland menschen gibt die sehen
wollen wie ihre lieblings youtube mit
einem telefonmast telefoniert ich habe
diese ganze sache wie immer ein recht
ähnliches feedback antoine bitte bleibt
stabil bleibt geistig gesund tut nicht
so als würdet ihr mit nicht existenten
kreaturen facetime macht's gut